[موسيقى]
واجهنا اليوم فريقا مصريا قويا يتمتع
بخبره كبيره في افريقيا لقد جئنا بافكارنا
وخطه لاعب المدرب التي نحاول الالتزام بها
قدر الامكان سنحاول ازعاج اكبر عدد من
المنتخبات في هذه البطوله يعني هدك لمنتخب
مصر وكنا نتمنى ان نشوف مصر في النهائي بس
ده توفيق من ربنا وعدم توفيق يعني الحمد
لله على كل شيء الحمد لله في السراء
والضراء النهارده جنتي مش في حالته الشنوي
برده متعور الفرقه مش في حالتها مش
مستعدين كويس عادي هي دي الكوره يعني
مالناش نصيب في كده بصراحه منتخب مصر ما
فيش تنظيم ا لعيبه ما فيش روح بيتحجج
بحاجه غريبه جو حراره رطوبه الكلام ده كله
على الناس كلها حاجات غريبه جدا بتحصل
اصابات اللاعيبه بتصاب في التمرينه ما فيش
ما يعني ما ما ما عندناش حاجه نقولها غير
ما يستاهلوش منتخب مصر ماكش يستاهل ان هو
يكسب اصلا النهارده ولا كان يستاهل ان هو
يصعد من المجموعه لاثه تعادلات والنهارده
تعادل مافيش اي اداء مافيش اي تنظيم مافيش
خطه المدرب واقف على الخط مافيش اي
تعليمات كل لعيب بيلعب
[موسيقى]
بمزاجه